- Wheee! (laughs)
- Nimco Mix.
- Suitable for vegetarians,
not recommended but suitable.
- This looks really fun.
- There's a lot going on here.
- Oh!
- So many flavors I don't recognize.
- Cinnamon and cardamom.
- I don't know what those are.
- It's like Chex Mix made of cologne.
- A little spicy.
- Oh, and it settles really well.
- This is like what bar food
would taste in a fever dream.
- It's pretty good.
- It's like I opened
every ramen flavor pack,
and poured it into my mouth.
- Guys like me who love spicy food,
this would make a perfect snack.
- [voiceover] It's Dal Moong.
- Delicious and crispy, let's see.
- This is the most fun.
- It looks like we've got
fossilized Rice Krispie treats.
- It's like if somebody wanted
to make fries out of rice.
- I kind of feel like
I'm eating dry lentils.
- I would actually suggest
never to eat this ever.
- These are great.
- Definitely crispy, not
quite delicious though.
- 'Kay, Badshahi Mix.
- Little bits of crunch everywhere.
- It looks like stir fry.
- You've basically just
given me instant ramen.
- I don't know what this
flavor is, but it's great.
- It's really spicy.
- This one taste like curry.
- It's really bad.
- It's weird cause it's dry
but it has the flavor of soup.
- I don't know why you just
don't make this into a chip.
- You tantalize all your taste buds.
- This is my favorite one so far.
- I probably wouldn't buy some.
- Like, I like everything (laughs).
- The next taste comes all
the way from snack city.
- Snack city bitch,
snack, snack city bitch.
- Chillz with a z.
- Little mini french fries.
- Yeah, they taste like sticks.
- They're nice, they
taste like french fries.
- They're really spicy at the end.
- The aftershock.
- (coughs) Ow (laughs).
- A sweet slow burn.
- I'd say overall they're super chillz.
- (singing) Shahi Deluxe it's the snack
that gives you cancer.
- Don't try this at home kids.
- Look at what it is (laughs).
- And we have McDonald's taste tests,
so this is nothing.
- Smells like, grandma's perfume.
- (laughs)
- How do you swallow this,
it's just in my mouth.
- Yeah they're rocks.
- Surprising this is the best
thing I've tasted all day.
- Yeah, it's kind of nice.
- Oh, it's so bad.
- (moans)
- My teeth are just
like being wedged apart.
- I'm actually into this.
- What are you guys doing over there?
- It's like my mouth is a waiting room.
- Mmm, yeah there's a very
crisp, distinct flavor to it.
- Pakistan has some good snacks.
- [voiceover] The finest
ingredients that guarantee
both great taste and a fun time (laughs).